so castrate your children that is the
message and some people bewilderingly
are following that there has been a huge
surge of young people being castrated in
the name of transgenderism Reuters
recently reported that in the past few
years 56 miners between the ages of 13
to 17 have undergone genital mutilation
in clinics around the country
776 miners have undergone mastectomies
having their breasts cut off and more
than 14
000 have been poisoned with hormone
treatment which will in a lot of cases
sterilize them for Life cause them
osteoporosis
and other problems so obviously this is
a very dark moment in our history a
civilized country would not put up with
that Hungary has a child protection act
which prevents any of this crap from
going on children from being sexualized
and because it has taken a stand against
sexualizing children Hungary is being
sued by over a dozen EU member states
Bosch Orbin is the political director
for Hungarian prime minister Victor
Orban one of the smartest people we've
ever talked about politics and he joins
us tonight Bosch thank you so much for
coming on
um so you are taking an unpopular
position that I think will be Vindicated
by history you personally have indicated
by history but right now it's got to be
hard why are you sticking to your
position in Hungary
good evening ladies and gentlemen thank
you very much Tucker for the nice words
and thank you for for having me well
actually the whole story started around
2021 when we in Hungary started to
realize that something is uh it's coming
it's like a storm which is coming woke
ideology or lgbtq propaganda is is
arriving to Hungary to schools through
media and through ngos and and you know
you can imagine how a Grassroots normal
Hungarian citizen reacted on that we
don't have the word Vogue in Hungarian
people were asking what are you talking
about Vogue is that the French magazine
or what but then they started to realize
that this is this you know this is
something serious and um in in in and
when we introduced the child protection
bill which bans
transgenderism and the lgbtq propaganda
for for minors then the whole Brazilian
bureaucracy and European Union were
going again answers then we decided to
turn towards the people and we organized
the national referendum when almost four
million people said no to to to to to
gender propaganda and said yes to Child
Protection Law is compared to the size
of America it would mean almost 130
million
supportive votes but then as it happens
The Empire Strikes Back and the
Brazilian deep State it's it's very
similar to the to the to the DC One it
started a legal persecution uh against
Hungary which is backed by many Western
European countries Eastern European
countries think differently but there is
an ongoing really political and legal
Cold War but we try to keep the fronts
up
so it sounds like you're not going to
back down no definitely not and you know
the Hungarian people are Hungarian
people are behind us so this is their
expectation this is you know my my job
is not to be popular among the Brazilian
Elise but but to represent the interest
of my people in Brussels this is why we
we have no other chance just to take the
battle
you anticipated my question amazingly I
was going to ask does the public support
this so just to be really clear in
closing a democracy is a government that
represents the will of its people you're
often called a dictatorship
but this policy reflects what hungarians
want just to be clear is that right true
true this is this is what Hungarian
wants it's it's out of uh out of
question and if the media the state the
big powers are against you you only
backing is the support of the people we
are very grateful for that one and we
have to serve them
yeah so if Samantha power doesn't like
it you're a dictatorship right I got I
got yeah the terms oh yeah yeah if you
are not with us then you are a
dictatorship this is how this foreign
policy looks like usaid immediately
launched a central European program uh
she visited our country and they really
are ready ready to Enlighten us yeah I
would keep her out of your country if I
were you blush Orban coming from one of
the last democracies in the west Hungary
thanks so much for coming on today thank
you very much
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight